first down and 10 to the 23 Sanders
again this time he finds Travis Hunter
Hunter looking for the first down picks
his way forward and gets close to it and
he may have it
third down Morris
intercepted wow Travis Hunter
unbelievable are you kidding me right
now that was wide open from the booth a
hundred times out of a hundred I see
that action from up here that's a
touchdown
the door Sanders looking
throwing it deep Sanders
and it's cut at the 40 guess who Travis
Hunter
[Applause]
adjustment the ball just a little bit
short and you see how he's got to stop
and go back second
ten
Ure Sprints out throws caught first down
Travis Hunter once again mistake and if
you're on defense can you find the time
to get up there and get a turnover
second down and nine Sanders bouncing
around
underneath and the ball is caught by
Travis Hunter what a day this man
unbelievable